okay hi everyone welcome to the Simon's
Institute I'm Shafi and I'm the director
at Simon's here and um
there's a
thing you always hear and that is that
we are dedicated to uh research and
theoretical computer science especially
collaborative research and uh you're
part of this uh I think amazing effort
and uh really our primary use of the
Simon Institute and there are programs
to explore uh algorithmic thinking in
science and engineering
and uh I guess to study the laws of
computation itself
so I'd like to welcome you to today's
Workshop the graph limits non-parametric
models and estimation
and um I think this is the first
workshop on the graph program right uh
we had a boot camp this is the first
Workshop out of three
and it's organizing collaboration with
eurandam in the Netherlands and I'd like
to really thank the organizers for their
um you know help and work actually not
help they do everything the organizers
of this program in putting together a
great program and these are suvik Dara
Christian Borg
um Sophia OLED and Marco abundis they're
Hofstra
for my own purposes who's who you are
okay nice to meet you
very good and Christian I know but he's
not here
um okay so I'd like to cover just a few
Logistics
um topics for this coming week and then
I'll pass uh
um so food is given before the first
talk and during the breaks you're not
supposed to bring uh food or drinks
besides water into the into the lecture
hall and in order to
show you what food means is this I was
not supposed to bring this
[Music]
and I will never do it again what
that's examples isn't it
it's sort of kind of a contradictory
manner but you will remember this
introduction and for lunch you're on
your own but there are a lot of great
places around here my one of my favorite
is rice and Bones it's also in the law
school which is to the this Direction
and The Business School in the other
direction
and um
again we ask you to leave food out of
the auditorium their lockers I don't
know if you've seen them on the side of
the building for those who don't have
offices on the first floor if you'd like
to leave Valley was there our
videographer sitting over there is amid
um and umidifara and he will help
speakers to really talk there's any
problem just kind of signal him although
the truth is he's always sort of on
watch of what's happening and our staff
person is Elizabeth Ewing over there
Elizabeth he was in charge of this
workshop and all the logistics
um and I guess in terms of uh this is
hybrid this Workshop all of our
workshops have been hybrid recently so
um the audience just raised their hands
and the people online
um somebody has supposed to monitor
their camera
okay so I'm gonna hand over things to
savik
um
you
now that I know and uh welcome everyone
I hope you have a great workshop and my
beautiful research
right welcome uh let me start by
saying thanks to you for participating
in this Workshop so this is the first
Workshop in graph limits so over the
past years as you know the graph limits
of large graphs has become important
across diver disciplines and in science
and technology and graph limits is like
the core concept that has been used to
Advanced questions in statistical
physics
statistics probability in different
fields right so we are lucky that uh in
this Workshop we have speakers who have
developed these fields and will be
listening to them and learning about
modern challenges in the field uh
so the workshop will have three
approximately three to four different
themes the First theme is graph limits
and its applications to combinatorics
and then applications to stochastic
processes and applications to statistics
and there are new emerging topics in the
disciplines such as graph on games graph
neural networks and we will be hearing
about those topics
so uh
uh we believe this Workshop will be the
ground for interdisciplinary
collaboration in graph limits and we'll
take the field forward the so Remco
Christian I we have been trying to get
together a meeting like this on graph
limits for a long time now since 2019
but the previous workshop at you random
had to be canceled unfortunately due to
covid-19 but we are really glad that we
could come together at the Simons
Institute and this Workshop could be
organized jointly with you random okay
uh so
let me say that in my experience in the
Simon's Institute that talks are super
interactive so if you have questions in
between please feel free to
participate and ask the speaker uh the
talks are approximately 40 plus Epsilon
minutes but Epsilon is between zero to
five so the the
speaker can at around 40 minutes the
session chair will tell you tell the
speakers that okay you have five minutes
left the speaker can then wrap up and
take questions and we can use that also
transition between talks okay
so uh
do you want to say anything else
Christian Remco
yes
Sophia got covered
still very tired from it
covered at the same speed as structure
um
she was here I actually wanted to stay
included
let's start with our first Speaker today
because she's worried from Facebook
floral Institute and Veterinary
Institute and will be learning about
random cluster models on regular gloves
thank you very much thank you for the
invitation it's a great pleasure to be
here this is a joint work with parents
bench and mask on board the parents
bench is my former PSC student postdoc
at Amsterdam and Martin Boardman is
this stock is in the realm of
statistical physics so it's an
application graph limit Theory to to
statistical physics
um so so what is the partition function
of the random cluster model so every
statistical physical model has a
partition function here if we have a
graph G then
we do the following thing we take all
that successor or over subsets of the
asset and a weight of a subset is Q to
the number of connected components of of
this subset including the isolated
vertices so if there are either vertices
this is a connected component itself and
W to the number of assets
if you met a random cluster model as a
percolation model then W is p over 1
minus B in that model
okay
so why is it
important
this uh
this or mother and there are many
different answers and one answer for me
as a combinator is but I wish you that
for a statistical physicist it is also
very important that it is actually just
a rapport of methodization of the
so-called that polynomial so that
polynomial is a divided polynomial where
we have an x minus one times the number
of connected components of this set a
minus the connected components of the
original graph times y minus 1 to the
number of connected components to a c
minus the number of vertices the V I can
remember this this quantities is the
following the super the gravity is
connected the first one is zero when it
is connected so it contains the spanning
tree the second one this is zero if a is
a 4S so it is content in the spanning
tree so the these are sort of competing
with each other these two
powers okay and as you can see you can
easily convince yourself that this is
really just a parameterization so so if
you know the number of connected
components and the number of edges in
each a that you of course know this
so there is a parallel story in
Columbiana traditionally random cluster
model in combinatorics it counts a lot
of things so Atlanta the third
polynomial
conquist the spend increase here
spending for this connected subgras this
is simply two different number of edges
but it can't some sense things also so
tg20 is the number of acidic orientation
so we Orient the edges and we see
whether there is a directive Circle and
if there is no other it's good it's an
acyclic orientation
and pg02 has number of strongly
connected orientations and also a
specialization of the third polynomial
is the chromatic polynomial polynomial
so it's really it really counts a lot of
combinatorial objects that are of
interest in statistical physics the
story that actually this generalizes a
lot of models so most probably really
you have heard about easy model but it
it just which is the psq equal to 2 but
if Q is any positive integer then this
is the so-called what's model and
general
q w and Q is bigger than zero and W is
bigger than minus one this is the random
cluster model
okay so there are two parallel stories
uh and I think this makes this whole
concept really important
actually growth and it also arise to
this concept
[Music]
is there any question and feel free to
interrupt me
okay so what's the problem I would like
to study today so
[Music]
we consider the following problem where
G and B and essentially large graph
sequence
so it means that this this means that if
you say can the number of triangles then
it's very legible to the number of
vertices also the number of poor Cycles
the number of five factors and so on and
so on so this is the essential adverse
sequence and now let's gmbs sequence of
essential Hardware sequence and I would
like to compute this limit
now one application if it is the
following so if you take a random B
regular graph a sequence then it is a
essential larger sequence so it's true
that for every fixed K if you consider
the number of cycles of length k then
its message and which is the number of
vertices actually
it converts to the person distribution
for each okay
so it's very strongly essentially the
address of course if you just don't like
this essentially then think of a larger
sequence so the length of the shortest
cycle tends to infinite damages
thank you
perhaps if your graphs are random you
need to zero in probability or almost
surely what unit
so it it
will converts I think the almost surely
so it is
okay
okay so what do we know about this
problem so Gamble and Montana resolved
this problem for easy Mother and
actually this saw the much more general
program
they don't insist on having regular
graphs but they consider this essential
large quests condition they call it
locally three lakh because there are no
short circles and the graph is located
so this problem for the Post model so
when Q is a positive integer except when
w belong to a an integral w w one that
there was some problem
yeah so
there is an interval where you have to
it's harder to understand the gifts
measures so bamboo Mountain lifestyle
son Ben saw the problem B is even and Q
is a positive integer so the missing
case here is only when these odd say
three and W belongs to this
exceptionally in type of it it's a bit
harder
solve this problem when Q is very large
and also they needed some explosion
property by the graph sequence there is
a case which is also very important when
we can graph colorings this is a bit
tricky uh in the sense that here this is
a
W is minus one so it's negative
so they solved it and very recently with
parents bench we solved this for the
task polynomial when X is at least one
and Y is between 0 and 1. so it it
actually as a special case it shows the
number of spanning for us and and
basically coordination so some some
turbine varieties not very trivial
okay so this is our main result
so we solve this problem when Q is at
least 2 and W is non-negative and
cream is the following so the limit
exists so this is one part actually and
and then we can compute the limiter
explicitly this is lmpdqv which can be
computed as follows take this rather
well ugly trigonometric polynomial it's
not that type actually so take this
trigonometric polynomial and compute it
on the minus Pi Pi interval and that
will be pi b Cube and then logging back
and that will be the limit
okay
um
well
well this trigonometric polynomial is a
bit funny because it's a linear
trigonometric polynomial
raised to the D's power so the D only
appears here in the exponents
so this is the queen is there any
question about it so we can compute very
efficient complete this limit
okay so that is a phase transition if
you fix Q it turns out that if if W is
smaller than some critical value this
critical value hit then this limit is
actually quite simply to complete this
is Q times 1 plus W over Q to the T hat
when the W is bigger than
WC then then we get a strictly bigger
quantity
cool
so this picture somehow summarize is
what we know about this program
currently for for uh
non-negative x file so this is X and
this is y and Q is x minus 1 times y
minus one so it's a high per Volo here
so Q equal to 2 is here
and so this talk is about this region
this region is our previous result with
Finance branch and we also know this
region as a byproduct we get it for free
of the other two results okay so
so we see what is missing yes
calculated yes so here it is first order
except at this point or two equal to
where it is second order for the raising
model it's not that the second order
everywhere has a first order
and these these formulas that you show
are they linked to duality
foreign
talk will be a bit more technical I I
know I'm I know that it is a bit more
technical actually the first part will
be quite easy to follow this uh
approximation of the partition function
so so the idea is that first we try to
come up with something which
approximates zgq W in a broad sense so
you will see this approximation is not
really a
a very good approximation it's just good
for pre-like local 3x so essentially
large glass sequences
um in the second part somehow that we
try to understand this approximation the
first part will be I think easy to
follow
um the second part will be a bit more
technical
don't worry if you lose something
okay
okay so let me speak about this
approximation part
so I will try to approximate it with
with the spin model so what is the spin
model so in a speed model we have a
symmetric Matrix and it it encapsulates
what's going on the edges and we have
vertex ways so when
this is an R by R Matrix what we do is
the following we write or
all different
vectors on the vertices we evaluate at
an edge what we get if we plug in the
event color 2 and color three here then
we have an n23 here we also get a mute
to add this vertex and then move three
at these factors okay so so this is a
screen model General it's much easier to
handle spin models because they are sort
of local you you can see at everywhere
that's what what it contributes to the
whole graph
okay I like with connected components if
you have connected components you don't
really know after that whether it's
height functions
Okay so
so when we have a post model this
corresponds to The Matrix when you have
one plus W in the diagonal and one of
the off diagonal and we have one
everywhere and it turns out that this
spin model has the same partition
function as the random cluster model for
this positive integer Q
okay uh
so
so let's try to approximate this forcing
and and for a moment let's assume that Q
is a positive integer this will give a
motivation so as I said the postmoda has
this Matrix
and let's try to approximate with this
very simple looking one where where we
have write one plus W A Q F be back so
the sum of all the entries is the same
here and here but of course when we
compute the partition function this one
then each Edge will contribute a 1 plus
W over Q so this is one plus W over Q to
the number of edges and we can write the
color version Q to the number of
vertices there so this is completely
trivial to compute
so I will call it the rank one
approximation and this makes sense even
if Q is not an integer we can navigate
it and when it is positive
okay so the first very easy Lemma is
that if Q is bigger than one then this
is actually a lower Bond
and if Q is between 0 and 1 this is an
after advance and this proof is really
violent and if you have a subset of
edges a then the number of connected
components is at least the number of
vertices minus the number of edges so
you
you plug in this lower Advantage Q is at
least one and you get exactly this
quantity by binomial identity
so we
in some sense it says that it is the
natural approximation although it's not
good always
okay so how do how to make a better
approximation and of course the previous
one was the rank one approximation where
the then parametrics now let's try with
that two Matrix let's try the following
thing we keep the first one first column
and then instead of this we take this
average W over Q minus one one plus W
over Q minus one everywhere so again the
sum is the same in this Matrix as the
sum of the entries here okay only we
change the this little bit and then we
can compute this as follows well if we
if we look at which vertices has color
one then it will be some s then we those
edges will give inside the 1 plus W to
the number of edges inside this set as
then the rest will contribute this one
so the number of edges in G minus s uh
1 plus W over Q minus n we can choose
the rest of the coloring in Q minus one
to the number of vertices minus
accessories so this is the same
okay and again the good news that it
makes sense if Q is bigger than one so
so we can forget this this uh motivation
with positive integers you this makes
sense for every cubic and balanced
you get the zero
okay and so of course this is again a
speed model we have 1 plus W for color
one we have a one plus W over Q minus
one for the rest we just call it the
rest and this test has a width Q minus
one so the vertex rate is suddenly hit Q
minus one and then we can add this way
so this again
the same formula
okay so what do we know about this one
uh first of all I need a landmark for
the original uh partition function so it
says that for the original partition
function we have the very same
identity PS before uh
only without the one approximation now
this is true for the following reason
this is true for positive integer Cube
just think about it as a matrix whether
again the color one has one s we have
polar Advan on the rest we have uh the
other colors Q minus one colors and we
have the same W so this is true for
positive integer two but on both sides
we see polynomials so this must be true
everywhere okay
so so if
oriented activity is easy to see for
other few this follows from having
polynomials and then we can use the
previous
Lemma to prove that if Q is at least 2
then we have a this this bank to
approximation is a lower band and uh
between one and tweets and not per band
so that's why we have result about Q at
least two because we need this low
advancing
okay now the main reason
in this section that actually not only
we have a lower bound but we also have
an upper bond which is a pulling so fix
some G can the number of Cycles at most
G that that BR and then an upper band is
q q to the N over G plus r times this
strength to approximation
okay so so why is it enough for us
because if you take the logarithm and
divide it by the number of vertices then
this will be 1 over G
there's nobody to few plus L Over N
times logarithm Now 1 over G tends to
zero if G tends to infinity and this L
Over N also tends to zero so this is
enough for us so it's not a very good
approximation but it is quite enough for
our purposes
Okay so
this way we see that if this limit
exists for this uh
then to approximation then or original
limit also exists
let's see that's done
okay so let me sketch the proof because
actually the the surprising thing that
the proof is is very short only two
slides three stars with this picture
so let's let's understand this picture
so we see a subset of the edges so the
board edges and then we see various
connected components connected
components on three vertices a connected
component on four vertices on one
vertices and the connected component on
two vertices
and I will call a connected component
large if it contains a cycle now this is
clearly large but this is also large
because the connected component actually
contains this triangle so it's large
even though the set here does not
contain a cycle but the induced
connected component does contain a cycle
so this is a large one and these are
small okay so large if it contains a
cycle small if it's not
so I will call the set of large
connective components earlier the set of
small connect quick compounds acid and
finally I need the concept of computer
compatible vertex that are this is just
the union of some small components it
might be empty so here a small component
is this one as this one or or this
together is a small vertex set
[Music]
so
so let's try to gather some easy
observation the number of connected
components is just the sum of the last
connected components plus the small
connected components so
the large connective I screen that the
number is Atmos n over G plus the number
of short circles because if a large
connected component either does not
contain a short cycle but it contains a
circle so it has at least G or it
contains a small cycle and the number of
small Cycles is this add GG okay so the
number of flash connective components is
can be bounded easily now we need also
this binomial identity it is really just
due to the number of small connected
components is the sum of Q minus one to
the whereas the number of sums more
connected components but the unit of
some small component connected
components was whether compatible set so
this is just a binomial identity it's
nothing else absolutely
and then
we can do the following
first we band this large connected
components using here and over G Plus F
this LG G is the same as this
then we get this one then we write this
binomial identity
here
and now what happens if I change the sum
so here I have a connected here I have a
r a compatible set it contains some
small connective component and and and
the
the complement is some large on the
large we don't know anything it can
contain Cycles or not so so I don't care
about those but so if I sum up for for
the complement then I just get
everything one plus W to the number of
pages because I don't know anything
about the component
on the other hand on the r this company
preset I know that we should see a
forest we should see a forest because it
does not contain cycle so the a itself
does not contain a cycle so when we sum
up for for R we can see a number of
connected components of of some subset B
which is a forest with some sum Okay so
so we arrived to this band and uh the
inner sum is quite easy to ban so if we
have a full rest on a set then we know
exactly what's the number of connected
components this is just the number of
vertex set minus the number of edges
because it support us okay so so here
the number of connected components I
should provide that on vertex R is R
minus d
okay and then if I forget this this is a
forest I I can get a binomial identity
and I get this one so so if I go back
now I managed to give an upper Bound for
this part
and then we had this contribution from
the complemental part where we don't
know anything and we have this
contribution here which is just the one
approximation and this together is is
the two approximation this is really the
two approximation and we are done
so
um maybe it was a bit fast it's probably
it's not the best way to
present people's lives but as you can
see this is very short two slides on the
picture
and here I don't I didn't use regularity
so it might be useful for instance
address any glass GNC over and so on
that
that might be a useful yes so I mean
you can use any regulatory
so so could your mechanism be used to
for example
the degree distribution converges
uh if if it is uh essential that first
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so heuristically this must be somewhat
related to that you're going to
approximation is exact of trees
yes yes
why is seven two approximation Etc
please I mean this gives a proof but I
want to understand it more obviously
well
uh
yeah I'm not sure that I can give a good
evidence to fight this immediately for
for this
the big idea is really this
the composition to large certain small
sets and uh more connected components
and then
there's more Collective components
really behave like trees and and
a question about it
exactly
actually for trees what you really get
is that uh
so for for locally three life since this
is okay uh for three is actually already
the the rank one approximation is
precise
is that because it's a regular Matrix
this one person W and device
yeah so already that would have been
enough for trees
okay
yes this is the phase transition uh this
is this is what I showed
but wow
exactly where they started so I had this
WC and below this this is the rank one
actually
this is just the land plan because if
you do this to the number of practices
and distributed the number of vertices
this is the number of edges so yes that
that's exactly the the test transition I
imagine yes very good question
okay now I will analyze this this
two-speed model because we have now a
very specific two-speed Model A one plus
W one plus W over Q minus one one and
VH1 Q minus one
nah actually the only thing we use about
that this is a phytomagnetic uh full
screen mode that so that terminative
this two by two Matrix is positive
that's the only thing we use about it
but here I use regularity probably
regularity is not really important but
for us it will be quite convenient
so so I so we have this very specific
two-speed model the strength to
approximation uh and we want to prove
that for essential that aggressive
pencil leader graphs uh this limit is
not the fun fact that this is actually
done so we could even we could have
finished our paper on page time I I
believe so so the point is that this was
done by bamboo and okay this is a bit
tricky to explain the story so
practically it follows from the work of
Dumbo and montanari but explicitly it
appears in in a paper of science sun
because they also because they work with
easy model but science shows that on a
regular graphs every two spin
phytomagnetics two-spin mode that is
okay so so we could have finished it
these are the papers of of this group
these are really fantastic papers so we
learned a lot from them we also learned
what what kind of thing didn't work for
them so we try to avoid also so they
always try to understand the gifts
measures on on this uh
and
that is a limitation oh that's at this
point it seems that the limitation of
this approach so with that I could try
to attack the partition function and
avoid gives measures
okay so so this is the
wizard of style and sun which is
actually just using
paper of Dumbo and montanari but if we
have a positive definite Matrix and so n
is positive definite Matrix maybe as
positive entries then there exists that
feedy and said that this limit ports and
then of course this is true for random
directly that's what so this is for
every essential large percentage
I I will show a stronger statement in a
minute and I will explain how to prove
it
so this is the result and actually two
things are true
if you know what is a barium Ministry of
convergent then you can forget the
locally like Condition it's more General
to have a biominational congression on
that sequence so then
of course it
to compute the exact limit is a bit
tricky unfortunately
the other thing but this is the same I
mean from the limit that is
because it doesn't I mean for example
foreign
and it turns out that if the graph G
contains a large number of short Cycles
so at least Epsilon times the number of
vertices equals g then we get an
exponential Improvement on that
partition function so what we get is
really a lower band actually
is that
two around one approximation here this
is
a two by two positive industry Matrix
and now we're going to approximation
with a special effects
but it's of the tree
oh yes yes
the best importance
yeah so so this is a lower abundant that
it comes with a lot of short side of the
foreign
[Music]
uh that's a good question just that we
don't know yeah um
thank you
okay so how to analyze this thing and
this is a bit technical but actually not
terrible technical so again we start to
introduce a new function and I call it
the sub graph counting polynomial so
here I sum up for all a subset of the
edges and and for the subset I compute
what's the degrees at a particular
vertices and then I introduced this new
variables x0x1 FD and and then I plug in
this product of X the degree at the
corresponding vertex
uh so let's let's consider that a
special case let's say the complete
graph from 5S this is it's for regular
so we have variable X on x x as the
export then this in the end is subgraph
every degree is zero so this will
contribute to x0 to the fifth in the
complete subgraph we are every degree is
4 so this is export to the fifths
and for instance if you want to count
the number of perfect matchings you just
plug in zero one zero zero zero zero
into this because a perfect matching is
a sub graph at every degree is one so if
you plug in one at X1 and 0 everybody
has 23 Kind of Perfect matching
foreign
but actually this is again just
evaluation
I'm running out of time so I just
explain what what's going on the first
thing that actually you can encode this
vgnu as
as a as an evolution of this subgraph
can't think
well an even more interesting thing that
you do not only can encode this
[Music]
Revelation but actually you can evaluate
it in many different ways so for
everything in a zero two Pi you get an
evaluation
and okay I skip all these things I try
to explain what's going on and another
example so super degree is eight so we
have the eighth regular graph Q is 5 and
W is one then if you elevate FG at this
Vector which is now you can imagine that
you get one Evolution and this this very
first number is actually the diaphan
approximation
but actually you can do a better thing
you can use another angle you get
another vector
and you also get an evaluation so if you
ever this FG here then you get a again
this this uh more than to approximation
for this one here the first coordinate
is actually the maximum of this this
trigonometric polynomial
and this Cube consider the sound
structure you can even realize that this
is must be a lower bound because because
at all degree we see a negative number
and even degree a positive but if you
consider a sub graph the number of odig
revertices is even so the minus sense
just
answers okay so that's why we get a
lower band because somehow we can use a
vector yes
yeah thank you uh so so that's why the
lower band and also this will be the
limit so this value so so what happens
that you have a lot of vectors each
Evolution and you just consider the
first coordinate and where the first
coordinate is Maxima that will be the
limit right and also welcome
uh
yeah I skip it
also this one let me mention that first
thing that there is a t one so also
another thing where all zeros of this FG
Vector with this extra Z has zeros on on
the on on a circle and this will give us
the limits thing so this Liang theorem
somehow transforms in into building
probably I skipped this technically
verse that we have a measure on the
circle and then this measure will
converge and then we get a little bit
for that
this is how on the phase transition
looks like this trigonometric function
so at Phase transition we have two
maximum they have at the same uh
evaluation and this is symmetric for for
this uh thing so so this trigonometric
function which I showed at the very
beginning is very very nice for the
phase transition and for the phase
transition the radius of this circle
which I showed you is is one so that's
how you describe it and that's all thank
you very much for your attention
all right thanks for very interesting
questions
and maybe while we are taking questions
the next speaker can set up
so questions
so sort of following one of the previous
questions so what is what are the
challenges to extending this to General
Degree distribution graphs I mean the
regularity is it just the explicit
constant at the end
well so
I used the regularity in the analysis of
this plan to approximation uh
probably this part should be some high
reverse but but I'm I think this should
be doable sorry
it's just very convenient because you
can use this little young
CRM and zeros on a certain limit myself
thank you but is there any reason or
motivation to look at the case when Q is
also going within because as you
mentioned most of the work or all of the
work works with Q3 of n is there any
reason to look at the other region with
you sorry oh the number of colors the
the oh I see sorry I see uh
yeah
um
that's weird yeah it's not good actually
one thing is interesting that the Q is
between zero and found the model behaves
completely different with them
so that's how
it's much more related to the number of
foreign
so this is completely different and and
we don't have it
I was thinking more about the body
problem we have lots of uh you know when
the number of colors is like but we can
talk later
how is this
for Q and between one and two which is
second order
oh
your results are fine so when Q is
between one and two we have all the
conjecture results actually and the
fifth transition is at the different
value is so I throw in this picture
yeah yeah
so but I had this picture
if you have q equal to two yeah
this Q is x minus one times is y minus
one
is that this other title with Q is equal
to one here we have X is equal to D
minus one
and we have this another piece
transition here is at this point
this is actually the fair Collision so 1
over D minus 1 is the circulation
threshold and and this D minus one is
we didn't check it actually for here all
the results are going to actually so we
have two interactions
maybe in the interest of time we can
have questions
I think
so our next speaker is Dan Krall and
we'll be learning about analytic
approach to quasi randomness
so
I think I'm ready can you hear me
I guess it's mostly the question for
those who are not here so but it's happy
that both who are